hello everyone
in a couple of months time from now
various institutes across the country
are going to conduct their exams and
interviews for the selection of phd
students here also in iit kharagpur we
are going to do the same
and so i thought that will be a good
time now if i share some tips with you
all so that you will have sufficient
time in your hand to incorporate some of
these tips into your preparation into
your work plan uh identify some of the
gaps in your preparation and fill them
accordingly but before going forward for
the benefit of those who may not be
familiar with me let me introduce myself
i'm a faculty member in the mechanical
engineering department of iit kharagpur
before this i was an undergraduate
student again here at iit kharagpur in
the mechanic engineering department and
i was also a pg student so i have
experience from both sides of the table
as an interviewee and as an interviewer
in fact over the past five six years i
have sat in approximately a dozen
interview panels but my experience is
limited to the design specialization
within mechanical engineering department
despite this narrow specialization i
think some of the tips that i'm going to
share will be generally applicable
across the different iits across the
different departments
and more generally to other
places also like the central
universities and the state universities
there will be some notable differences
but i think the general tips will be
beneficial to all of you
okay so for the interview part uh the
first question that we generally ask is
please introduce yourself give us a
little background starting from your
undergraduate days in some cases we may
also ask you about uh your results
starting from the 10th class 10th boards
now we have all of this data in our
hands despite that we ask this question
just that uh you feel a little bit less
nervous uh
you can get over your initial jitters
because we are all human we feel a
little bit nervous with when facing an
interview panel
uh and believe it or not uh
we always want to extract the best out
of the candidate okay so the phd
interview uh so this is the first tip or
an inside uh peek into the thought
process that goes into a phd interview
that i'll be sharing with you is that
it's not an elimination procedures it's
a proper selection procedure so uh have
a little hurt
in knowing this
okay so we want to extract the best out
of you
so after this initial uh
some kind of a small talk is over uh
we'll ask about your broad interest and
also about your specific research
interests
uh
now for broad interests uh for example
if you're in mechanical engineering you
may say some things like solid mechanics
fluid mechanics acoustics uh
thermodynamics
and for specific research interests uh
you can say
so usually what what happens is that the
students say something along the lines
of their master's level project
and that's fine
but
there is a little bit of a uh of a thing
which you must be careful about
uh and it is that sometimes i have
noticed that the candidates uh when they
are stating this kind of a research
interest they state it in such a fashion
that it appears that they are not
willing to work on anything else
okay so that's rather unfortunate so you
should present your research interest in
such a fashion that it shows that you
have some research interest based on
what you have done during your masters
but at the same time you should also
even some kind of an open-mindedness
towards pursuing some other projects
because trust me
it may not always be possible that the
place where you are interviewing may be
having a research program or a project
with any of the professors uh which is
in sync with your master's level project
okay so please keep that in mind so
please show some kind of an
open-mindedness about it let me go on to
the actual interview the the question
answer type of things
so
before i share with you any tips
i want you to understand a little bit
about the philosophy behind us behind us
the interviewers asking you some
technical questions
okay so
uh it's something like this that
one may always question that despite the
written examination despite all the
academic records that you have all the
all the examinations that you have gone
through since your undergraduate days
why are we making such a big fuss about
asking these questions during the
interview
okay so it's something like this that
you say during phd you are not going to
tackle some kind of a known problem by
its very definition your work will be on
some kind of an unknown problem whose
answer is not predetermined okay after
you have solved something you do not
have a textbook at the back of a
textbook where you can actually look at
the answer or to match your answer so
what do you do well you think about what
you have found out your solution okay
you you try to gauge the physical
meaningfulness of your solution and try
to think that perhaps if you have if you
had taken some kind of other solution
methodology would you perhaps have
arrived at different sort of answer so
this kind of of a juxtaposition of
different ideas uh
thinking in a very broad-minded way
about uh in a broad-minded as well as in
a very dispassionate way about your own
uh solution strategies that is what is
required okay and that requires some
kind of academic maturity and it is this
academic maturity whether you have it or
not
that is something that we wish to gain
an insight into uh by asking you these
technical questions so on this note what
i would say is that i've always
i've often times seen
this happening to many of the students
many of the candidates that when they
come for the interview when we ask them
some question
they do not
express themselves fully maybe it is a
little bit out of nervousness or maybe
they have gotten some kind of an advice
that
they should be very very precise in
their answers but please note that
precision in your answers is not at odds
with the brevity of your answer you can
be precise but long in your answers you
can be elaborate in your answers but
still be precise okay so through the
interview we actually want to gain an
insight into your thought process
okay this is very very important i have
it it has happened many a time that the
student may not be actually arriving at
the correct answer uh or the correct
solution that we are asking him to solve
or our answer
but
just by giving us a proper glimpse into
his thought process into his or her
thought process we have gone on to
select those candidates okay because we
like the way that he or she is trying to
think and work his way into the problem
okay that kind of uh of a of a long form
uh
very very analytical thinking when he
shows up a plus at the same time it also
shows that he has a good communication
skill because when this student is
actually selected and and goes on to
work with a particular professor
on a very on on a regular basis he has
to discuss things with the professor so
unless he has this ability to
communicate what he's thinking what he
or she is thinking then how will the
professor be able to work with him okay
so this is very very important and this
is something which you haven't have a
great opportunity to show during the
interview and you must take full uh full
advantage of this opportunity okay so
the interview is actually an opportunity
for you to display this ability that you
may have in front of the professors okay
if you succeed in this a lot of your
work is actually done okay let me give
you give you a very specific example uh
so since i am from a mechanical
engineering background i'll try to give
an example which will be generally from
this uh quite important from this
mechanical sciences so it will be
beneficial for students of mechanical
engineering civil engineering aerospace
uh maybe even naval architecture so uh
it's a very popular question
suppose we ask you what is the reynolds
number okay now many of you will jump at
this question and say that it is the
ratio of inertial forces to viscous
forces okay great
so our next question perhaps will be
something like okay tell us the formula
of the reynolds number now this may seem
apparently like a very information based
question and perhaps an undergraduate
student who has just learned fluid
mechanics in his previous semester he
may immediately say something like re
the reynolds number is equal to rho v d
by mu
but
we expect a little bit of more maturity
from a potential phd candidate
okay so
some of you who are a little bit more
sophisticated would have already
detected where i'm going with this
you see during the interview if you face
such a situation don't immediately jump
to the actual formula that you maybe
know think about it pause a little bit
and this actually goes beyond this this
this very particular example of reynolds
number that i'm saying this is just a
specific case uh just to concretize our
thought process
that
you perhaps you can ask back to the
interviewer that whether he or she is
thinking to the professor actually you
ask
that
are you perhaps thinking of an internal
flow or an external flow
the moment you ask a ask back to the
interviewer a question like this
then it shows that you have some
academic maturity okay you will
immediately see some kind of a spark
enlightening in the in the eyes of the
professor okay he will immediately think
okay this guy is not any run-of-the-mill
candidate okay there is something
special about him or her and we need to
prod him we need to extract the best out
of him
okay so
after he or she says uh so this will
actually encourage a little bit of a
discussion and you as an interviewee
have this ability and power in your hand
to direct or orient the disk on the
direction of your own interview okay
so when you know something stay on it
discuss things around it okay
it will help you to highlight your own
strengths this is one of the like if you
if you have to pick one big tip from
this entire video let this be
okay that you can orient the direction
of your own interview it can so happen
that the interviewer next asks you a
question again on the reynolds number
but based something on your research
interests now many students
across various institutes they are
working on
microfluidics micro scale flows
low renault number flows so
be prepared to face some kind of a
googly question
okay
so perhaps you may be asked something
like
okay
you have a flow where the reynolds
number is small but not so small that it
is much much less than one
despite that
uh
do you know of a situation where the
reynolds number is perhaps larger than
one but still we can drop the non-linear
terms
from the left-hand side of the
navier-stokes equation
okay so now the answer of course is yes
that in lubrication type of flows uh
where the
and the the thickness of the confinement
is much smaller than the the the lateral
length scale so
the h by l ratio is so very small that
it actually uh
helps to helps us to drop the terms the
non-linear terms from the navier-stokes
equation okay so this is the very very
common lubrication approximation so now
things like this okay
on the on the counter side perhaps you
have worked on your masters on
microscale flows and the interviewer
wants to maybe broaden or maybe wants to
prod whether you have a broader
understanding of fluid mechanics and so
staying on the topic of reynolds number
only maybe he can completely turn the
table and ask you something regarding
large reynolds number so maybe you are
more familiar with smaller nulls number
maybe he can ask you something more
larger number so we go into maybe a
question uh from boundary layer theory
okay so
uh maybe you'll be asked something on on
the assumptions of boundary layer theory
maybe you can be asked something on ah
on the uh the relative lens skills
involved uh for hydrodynamic boundary
layer and the thermal boundary layer so
a lot of the questions can follow along
from there okay
and during your preparation i would
suggest that
try to get this kind of very broad uh
perspective of what you have studied
from different kinds of subjects
okay so uh try to connect the various
things the reynolds number the prandtl
number the pecking number so the all
these non-dimensional numbers they are
not just little definitions stacked up
in a table okay somewhere in your
textbook they are actually gateways into
connecting the different strands of
learnings that you have had in your
undergraduate and your masters
okay so enough of fluid mechanics
i personally don't teach fluid mechanics
anymore i did it from 2016 to 2018.
let me go on to solid mechanics okay and
and i've enlisted some uh questions let
me share with you some of those uh
so just to give you an example okay so
if you're from mechanical engineering
civil engineering aerospace uh maybe
naval architecture again uh you'll find
some benefit into this oh by the way
there's also the chemical engineering
guys certainly okay if i forgot to
mention chemical ensuring i think okay
for solid mechanics
now uh one of my personal favorite
questions is to ask the candidate uh
about uh about the concept of the
traction vector and invariably i will
see that uh the the candidate doesn't
know this okay so this is perhaps a
weakness of some of the
uh from the educational institutes that
they have been through
in certain places they don't teach all
these things
but
but
especially if you are from a good
institute like an nit or maybe another
iit there is absolutely no excuse for
you not to know about traction okay then
you be careful okay if you're from a
good institute you should know all of
these things okay so if you don't know
about traction
go and study it okay the traction
vectors it's an absolutely fundamental
concept in solid mechanics next
uh
so stress equilibrium equations it's a
very common question which
in one place or another you will
invariably face
but since you're at the phd level now uh
at the interview level of a phd
candidate so
uh
it's not just uh saying things like del
sigma x x del x plus del sigma x y del y
plus all those things i mean you know
all these things the stress equilibrium
equations but maybe you'll be asked
something like uh uh under what
conditions will you obtain the stress
equilibrium equations from the cauchy's
equation of motion okay the quotient
equation emotion is just general
equation of motion which is applicable
even in fluid mechanics solid mechanics
okay and especially if you are
saying that your research interest in is
in fluid solid interaction kind of
problems then you should know all of
these things very well okay so how do
you obtain the stress equilibrium
equations uh basically the divergence of
sigma
from the coach's equation of motion
uh and there's a this these kinds of
questions are pregnant with
possibilities of entire discussions okay
you can have hours and hours of
discussion on these things so brush up
on these things
they can be a big googly question okay
uh insoluble mechanics which is to do
with incompressible solids okay it's a
fascinating topic uh if you have gone
through a good textbook on elasticity
you will have invariably learned this
okay if you don't know learn it okay
it's a fascinating topic very very
interesting incompressible solids so
many of you are familiar with
incompressible fluid or incompressible
flow but there is such a thing as
incompressible solid also okay
so
brush up on that
next is regarding boundary conditions so
this is an extremely extremely important
topic for actual practical problems and
you should be very clear on the on on
things like continuity of displacement
continuity of traction
uh
and and how they may be applied uh for
particular cases so for example we may
give you two different materials which
are stacked up like that so what happens
at this interface okay so
if you don't know this again take up a
good book on elasticity a brush up on
the fundamentals you should be good okay
it's not difficult you just need to have
very clear visualization and
understanding of the fundamentals
uh next i have often often seen like
there's not a single interview that i
have uh i've i've sat on uh where this
where there's a number of candidates who
have said that the research interest is
on composite uh materials okay every
time it happens uh
and i'm sure many of you viewing uh this
this video uh may already be interested
in composite materials so i thought i'll
just point it out that you know fine it
is good that you are interested in in
such a hot topic but
please make sure that if you say that
your research in interest is in
composite
materials or mechanics of composites
that you are absolutely absolutely clear
with the material symmetries okay so the
constitutive behavior uh like
transversely isotropic orthotropic and
whatnot
so you have a very very clear
visualization of these kinds of material
symmetries okay
and not just saying things like okay
there are two independent material
constants or four independent material
constants not just that okay so anybody
can mug up those things but a proper
visualization of the symmetries involved
okay because he will be invariably asked
questions on those things
next uh
sometimes i have myself asked questions
like this that uh
suppose some student says uh that okay
divergence of sigma are the stress
equilibrium equations or divergence of
sigma plus rho b the body force per unit
volume uh equal to zero that's the
stress uh equilibrium equation i'll ask
something like okay what is the ah what
is the
nature of this equation is it a vector
equation or
what kind is a scalar equation what kind
of an equation it is okay and
like very surprisingly i have found and
very unfortunately also that students
sometimes fumble on this okay they know
that the stress is a second order tensor
they know this very well
but despite that
sometimes they just falter okay so
please again brush up on it
a very very important warning so to say
is that i've often seen that sometimes
when students don't know something uh to
a some
obscure solid mechanics question
they just come up with i don't know why
they say this sometimes they just
randomly say
compatibility equations okay please
please do not do this okay so
compatibility equation is a very very
specific thing it is
i believe it is one of the hardest
things to understand
uh
i am sure many other professors will
also agree there's a there's a whole
richness to it which you really really
need to appreciate well so unless you
have a very clear idea of compatibility
equations don't just randomly say okay
and on that note
brush up what the comparability
equations are
all right
next there's a very popular question uh
since i do a lot of a little bit of work
uh
regarding buckling uh
sometimes people ask this question so
it's a very old old question uh
what's the difference between buckling
and bending okay very classical question
uh for an interview uh so there you have
it now go and study what what's the
difference okay so uh yeah and and
generally if if you if your research
interest has something to do with
buckling please make sure that you
understand buckling uh more generally as
a form of instability and not just that
limited concept of euler buckling which
you have only studied in your
undergraduate days okay so uh so when
you go when you open up your mind to
this possibility that buckling is a
general form of or it's a is just one
instance of of of a general mechanical
instability then
you you you open your mind up to the
possibility of wrinkling that may happen
in plates uh so there's a whole
fascinating world out there
please please please do take a look into
that also okay so especially if you have
worked on place and things like that uh
we would expect you to know things uh
like this
all right
now
these are some of the very general tips
uh i thought that i'll i'll share with
you uh probably it'll be of a more
benefit to the uh to the non-surgical
branches
the computer science electrical
electronics guys will not find too much
use of this but i hope that through
these questions um
especially that earlier discussion
regarding the reynolds number thing i'll
have i have given you some glimpse about
the kind of twists and turns that
professors present you with during the
interview and please note that
during the course of the interview if
you actually see that the professor
or the interview panel is asking you
some twisting type of questions please
do not feel discouraged it is actually
good that they are asking you this
because they have gone past that stage
where they are just asking you
information based questions which
just any good hard working student can
answer now they are going to the realm
of questions which are actually prodding
your thinking process so they are trying
to extract that special something out of
you so feel very encouraged that you and
that it is going well okay and final
note
uh when you're uh when you're faced with
a question and you feel that you don't
know the answer to it please be very
honest about it and say that you don't
know okay it is much better that way the
bad thing about you beating about the
bush when you don't know the answer is
that first of all like it two things can
happen two kinds of impressions can
create first is that you have not even
understood the question that is why you
are beating about the bush
the second is that
maybe you have understood the question
but you're beating about the bush
because you don't have a proper academic
integrity okay you're just trying to
bluff your way out of it so either way
it creates a very bad impression on you
okay and trust me especially the senior
professors they have seen all varieties
of answers from students when they don't
know the answer they can easily quick
very immediately they can pick up that
you are trying to bluff your way out of
it okay so please don't do this if you
don't know just say that you don't know
or maybe that you've just forgotten they
will ask you a different question and no
harm done okay not much harm done
all right so
that's all about it
i'm sure i'm missing out many millions
of others other tips uh but you are all
intelligent guys through this little
brainstorming thing uh i'm sure you can
you can pick up the kind of thought
process that goes into
into the into the interview session
and i personally am actually looking
forward to recruiting uh
a couple of phd students uh this summer
so wouldn't be just wonderful that
someone out there watching this video uh
actually ends up
being my own student my own phd student
that would be just wonderful so on that
positive hopeful note i will end this
video thank you very much and all the
very very best